so how are you doing today
I'm doing really well how are you
perfect congratulations on this this
gorgeous film it's just it's such an
important story to tell and I'm Glenda
so glad it's gonna be out there in the
world thank you so much so you were you
were focusing on music a lot you were
and I've seen you say that it would take
something special for you to jump back
into the acting role and I'm wondering
what it was about
boy erase that struck you was as special
enough to to go back into that world
yeah I mean I felt like as much as I
wanted the project to be special I also
just felt like logistically it was it
was it was gonna be tough to find
something that that kind of worked you
know I knew that I wanted I wasn't ready
for like a lead role you know what I
mean I want to kind of ease my way back
into things so it needed to be something
small I wanted to have some like meat to
it you know and be kind of dramatic and
and then I I really wanted it to have
you know to say something and as soon as
I got this script kind of every
everything went out of the window and I
was like you know as much as we're
trying to make a great movie here this
is like this is a message this is
something that needs to be there's a
goal here you know and so it became much
more about that than it did about about
making anything else so I just kind of
threw myself at it
we uh we kind of only see your character
in the context of the camp we only see
him we don't really see his life around
it did you did you work with with Joe at
all or by yourself to come up with with
his life around the camp his backstory
what brought him there stuff like that
totally yes so like in my head Gary was
he's kind of been like enlightened you
know he's off at college and got a
boyfriend and dyed his hair blonde and
pins his nails and stuff and and then
his parents find out and kind of maybe
they're financially supporting him or
something like that and pluck him out
and put him back into this camp and if
you look in the movie if you look super
closer you can see kind of like chipped
nail polish and the rooty blonde hair
you know it's growing out now and that
stuff was really important to me too to
include because you got to sort of play
with this backstory like that did you
layer in anything personal anything that
you sort of felt like it was it was you
putting yourself into his character
totally I think that's why I kind of
built him in that way was it was it was
a way for me to relate to him you know
it's like if if God forbid I was ever
kind of taken out of his life that I'm
in right now and put into something like
that I think I would have kind of a
similar reaction of I will do anything
in it everything that I have to do to
get out of here you know and you kind of
it gave him this air of like I you know
I don't want to say it's not pretentious
or anything like that but it's almost
like he kind of he just knows that
there's so much more to the world than
this and it kind of gives him this like
aloofness almost that I wanted to work
in there as well what did it mean for
you that your character really is the
the first character to say to Lucas's
character it doesn't have to be like
this and he's sort of the the guiding
light the first guiding light in the
movie for him when everyone else is
talking but has to be like this it has
to be like this what didn't view that
your character is the first person to be
like this this isn't the only way it
doesn't have to be like this so there's
so few moments of you know of that kind
of that alternative in in the film and
so I remember when I first read the
script there's a great scene between
like Jared and his doctor whereas his
doctor kind of also provides him this
like alternative where she second you're
a perfectly normal healthy young boy and
I just remember reading it being like
finally someone is like talking some
sense you know and and speaking like a
language that I understand you know and
so to to be a part of that moment for
for Jared and kind of be a part of that
really pivotal moment for him I think I
felt satisfying I think it felt so good
in your 23-year 23 years old you're sort
of the same age that Luke Lucas's
character is in the film and I'm
wondering if you you had a voice like
that in your life that really helped and
how important you think that voice is in
in real not just not just in the movie
but in a person's real life how
important that voice to say hey it
doesn't have to be this way is is for
you and and for anyone watching this
film for me that voice was the internet
access and because I didn't really know
any queer people growing up at all and
so I went online and I found people that
were like sharing their coming-out
stories on YouTube and
you know then I'd watch videos of pride
parades and I just saw this weld out
there of people who were like ready to
accept me for exactly the person that I
was and it changed my life so I think
that that voice is extraordinarily
important that's why I try so hard to
kind of just be as proud as I possibly
can be in in my everyday life so that
you know hopefully one day someone will
come across the music video or this film
or something and and then it can
actually make a real difference in their
life as a young entertainer actor
musician what does it like to just sort
of watch my falling actors like Nicole
Kidman and Russell Crowe just just do
their thing what did what did you gain
from just watching them work I mean it's
so incredible it's like it's kind of
like magic but at the same time one of
the most interesting thing is things is
that it's kind of that moment where you
realize as a kid that even your parents
are still figuring things out you know
what I mean like I'll look into coal and
I'm watching a sunset and she's she's
doing it slightly differently every take
and and things like that that I'm just
watching and I'm like wow this person is
it's just a talented person who cares so
much about about her craft and who's
become a master of it because of that
exact reason and so it just motivates me
to want to do as much of it as I
possibly can and to never lose that um
that desire to do better you know
you